how unbelievably astoundingly unlikely
our own existence
is against the spectrum of possible
combinations of base pairs of DNA
against the spectrum of possible
molecular configurations against the
spectrum of possible outcome of quantum
processes right that that stretch from
the beginning until today that each of
them could have turned out one way
versus the way they did yielding
Universe in which we wouldn't be here
against these astounding odds were here
and to me that's the beginning of the
most fruitful compelling and satisfying
approach to finding some sense of
purpose or meaning because